zach making his first start this season
last year and 11 starts at an earned run
average of 2.92
swing gonna miss 100 miles an hour one
out here in the first
it was 98 99 down and then 100
up no chance none
swinging a miss 98 second strikeout for
wheeler
and a call strike three go two pitch
kevin
a swing and a foul tip he got it one two
three
four strikeouts for wheeler that was 97
and it was exploding down in the zone
[Music]
nicole strike three slider on the
outside part of the plate
five strikeouts for zach wheeler there's
the 2-2 pitch to swatson
swing gonna miss 99 on the fastball
six strikeouts for wheeler
a call strike three went with the slider
and he got him looking
seven strikeouts for zach wheeler
he has struck out the last four hitters
mueller struck out his first time up and
he loops one out to center field that's
a base hit
it past the diving albies segura is
going to score
rbi single for wheeler it's a couple
years in the making and the phillies are
on top one to nothing
swinging a miss 98
eight strikeouts for will he's retired
13 in a row
line drive down the left field line
that's a base hit going to the corner
one run is in dede's being held to third
it's an rbi double for zach wheeler he's
doing it all
halfway to the cycle top four nothing
phillies wow
that is huge yeah the 2-2 from wheeler
swing gonna miss strikeout number nine
and that's 16 in a row
the 90th pitch of the day swing and a
miss
number nine as far as double digits
strikeouts
they know that it's three outs the
inning is over
ten strikeouts 17 consecutive hitters
he wanted to keep on going
you